cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com last night uh we had social
breakdown in Philadelphia Philly police
arrest 52 people in connection with
rioting and louing so basically last
night you had absolute Insanity in
Philadelphia over a hundred people
running around smashing Windows breaking
into into stores and liquor stores just
stealing whatever they wanted and uh
they didn't care they didn't care about
the police they didn't care about what
was going on and the police can't stop
it there is an influencer named meatball
yeah livestream got arrested for
stealing bread from an Apple Store
bread bread yeah wait what just uh you
know they're they're just trying to get
by just trying to get food too that's
right keep surviving right because
that's what AOC said right that they're
just struggling to get by so yeah you
know they went in bad for meatballs I
was picturing just meatballs and a nice
juicy hoagie roll and I kind of lost
track of the story for a second but yeah
do they feed their families with Dior
handbags I don't know well I've never
tried was when they stole all the Apple
products and went outside the alarms on
the dices went off saying you're being
tracked so they smashed them all yeah
but this is this is my point that I made
earlier when I talk about social
breakdown
let me spell it out for you if police
are not held accountable when they
commit crimes then you get this
what do you think the political
equivalent of this would be so I'll give
so I'll give an example
uh I don't believe that all caps are bad
I think that's silly uh the acap people
are are nuts I think police have a
purpose but the problem is when we get
instances of police impropriety we are
not likely to get accountability I can
speak to an example when uh the example
I often give of when I filmed the police
wrongly arrest a photographer in New
York who then filed a false police
report and lied and additionally lied
under oath to try and convict a guy who
had done nothing wrong the police
claimed that he was standing in the
middle of the street blocking traffic
when he was on the sidewalk and I filmed
him on the sidewalk and they arrested
him cops lied they just didn't want a
photographer taking pictures of what
they were doing there was never any
accountability for those cops now you
get a piece of information like that
it's a problem how do we fix it I don't
know it's it's this there's got to be a
solution to it the leftists propaganda
is that amplify it and then lie about
other instances because this seed means
you get a George Floyd you get an
omelette Aubry no one will trust the
police yeah it doesn't matter if you're
a fan of the cops or not the point is
this
the more stories you get and the more
videos you get of police and propriety
going unpunished you'll end up with
people like this saying the police have
no jurisdiction over me why would I
listen to the these gang members if and
that's what I've explained before if a
gang member subject hasn't says I'm the
boss now do as I said you'd better get
out of here if a cop shows up now you're
like okay I gotta call my lawyer they
have a warrant now I gotta listen what's
happening now is police are being viewed
no different than another gang now I
think about the political equivalent to
this if politicians in Congress can
Insider trade with no accountability we
know they're corrupt we know they're
taking these dirty deals we know they're
playing dirty games in politics we now
know that Democrats are going after
Trump supporters they're going after the
president himself they're solving his
businesses what's the political
equivalent
you're going to get factions of in
combination with this and the politics
what you will see is regular guys in
their neighborhoods starting
neighborhood watches yeah they're going
to say the police won't stop the crime
the police can't be held accountable the
government is going to arrest us we have
to protect ourselves what happens when
you get 56 different factions all
throughout the United States in their
small town areas asserting their
jurisdiction outside of the county the
state or the federal government
a Birth of a Nation yeah it's look it's
the way you're describing it is to the
extreme extent but at the smaller level
you know when people are just starting
these Community watches and they're
maybe just arming themselves and they're
just making sure that if you exercise
your second amendment rights that people
are going to be more polite around you
that's all good stuff you know it I
don't want to sound like I'm just trying
to make lemonade out of lemons here and
and I'd like to avoid Civil War if if we
can do that but if if people have a
little bit more situational awareness
now and people don't spend their time
hanging around downtown Philly because
it's going up in flames and people start
exercising their rights and and working
with their neighbors to say Hey you know
we're not gonna we're gonna make sure
this is a small town try that in a small
town man yeah I mean look these guys
could be could be canceled right but
like I don't know I like a little
accountability so so here's what I
imagine
these people are smashing businesses and
Flash mobbing all over the place it's
been happening non-stop for several
years now and it's getting worse this is
the worst we've seen not only are they
targeting stores now you have 100 people
running through the shopping district
and smashing up a bunch of stores
and the police are only able to stop
around half
you're going to get people who say try
that in a small town try that in a small
town what's the implication there the
implication is that we in a small town
will defend ourselves we will shoot you
that is so it's the subtext and here's
what happens there will be people in a
neighborhood in a suburb in a blue state
that will have guns the police will show
up and say we are coming to take your
guns away and those people are going to
be like f you no you're not because you
don't protect us from the flash mobs and
the roving gangs that are shooting at us
and killing people and the plays are
going to say shut your mouth and get on
your knees
welcome to a modern Lexington and
Concord I don't think that that'll it'll
come to that though it seems like maybe
maybe because we got the internet maybe
because we're American we've got this
culture that the cops are kind of like
pissed off at this like local cops don't
want to go harass people and take their
weapons they don't want us to create
that kind of animosity I don't agree I
think if a cop gets in order to go take
some guy's gun they're gonna be like no
no you do it dude I'm not gonna step in
front of that guy's okay Second
Amendment I got one I got one for you
Ian if uh the police were ordered to
arrest local local uh community members
in their own City because foreign
Nationals had entered do you think the
cops are back I'm not going to arrest
the guy who lives here because you want
me to protect a foreign citizen do you
think they do it I don't know they did
it already the police in Staten Island
arrested the local residents who were
protesting their government shipping in
non-citizens and paying them the police
arrested the people who live there how
about the guy was in his own home when
BLM showed up protesting and the man in
his own home knowing these guys had set
fire to another house recently
brandished a weapon the cops went into
his house and arrested him
you know you know the sad part of all of
this I mean that's all pretty sad
I think people will just probably go
along with it I I like to think they're
going to say no I'm going to stand up
for my rights and my way of life and but
man if even Staten Island can be pushed
around those are like the most obnoxious
you know sort of stubborn people we
talked about this last night the
American Revolution took 20 years it
started in 1764 and it went until 1783.
the the revolution started one year and
a month before the signing of the
Declaration of Independence and the
Battle of Lexington Lexington and
Concord which wasn't really a battle was
a bunch of farmers shooting at
effectively police the reason why that
marked the start the shot heard around
the world was because before this
everyone said exactly what you were just
saying right now no one's going to stand
up for themselves no one's ever going to
get into conflict with the regulars no
one will stand against the crown until
one day when the crown said we're coming
to take your guns and they went to the
militias in the rural parts of
Massachusetts and they said over our
cold dead hands someone started shooting
we don't know who I I think it's fair to
assume it was the Americans who opened
fire on on the crown first I think some
drunk militia man like yeah I don't
think that was it at all I think 300
regulars marching down the street
pointing muskets at you and one guy
somebody did not trigger we're just like
I'm done with it this is my fear but the
problem is I don't see enough for him as
Phil the body describes it because all
we ask for is like guys it's a really
simple police you can't arrest a local
resident because they're upset you
shipped in non-citizens to their
neighborhood and are giving them their
tax dollars let me make this clear for
everybody non-citizen illegally enters
the country gets a free bus ride or
plane ride to your hometown to Staten
Island to where you live
your tax dollars to New York City are
now paying these non-citizens who also
have police protections from you and
special protected status that AOC has
fought for
they're working underground jobs and
they're not paying taxes yo I'm sorry
man I'm I'm deeply concerned about
things like that I'm deeply concerned
about the fact that Colorado has no
abortion restrictions and Oklahoma has
total abortion restrictions hyper
polarization but but most importantly
the immigration thing I think is the
scariest thing yeah but but think about
how effective it's been you know we're
we're paying attention to it now in
particular because you see the crazy
stuff in Staten Island where you see
lampedusa gets overrun with more
migrants than citizens of this of the
island but this has been going on now
for over about 65 years the movement of
people into the United States over the
last 65 years is the largest movement of
people ever in recorded history so you
know the hour is a bit late on this
issue and there's this bizarre fact that
no matter which party you elect you just
get more more migration the the hour is
a bit late but all that means to me is
that it'll be worse than it should have
been if 50 years ago or whenever it
started people just said hey hey we're
stopping this right now now there's no
conflict you just sign the paperwork and
things are done maybe a little heated
arguments in Congress but now we're
talking about million a million plus
people per year now we're at the point
where the people who hey look man all
that is required for evil to Triumph is
good men do nothing good people do
nothing right and so the people of
Staten Island but mostly men I think we
know right sure but but the people of
Staten Island did nothing these are
people who who pay taxes and support a
machine and say leave me out of it I
don't care about politics I don't think
about that stuff that's the one
Republican Borough there you go and then
one day they wake up
and there's a bus being shipped in of
non-citizens and they're saying hey your
tax dollars everyone's got a pitch in
for these guys and they're like wait
these 20 year old men from El Salvador
and well sorry not El Salvador
Salvador's doing really well and
everyone's moving back but from
Guatemala no seriously though but from
Honduras and Guatemala who are fleeing
here then when they come out and they
say hey get this bus out of here the cop
looks them straight in the eyes with a
joker grin and says I will crack you
over the skull if you stop what we are
doing to your home and then what happens
the cops beat and arrest the people who
live there to protect the non-citizens
yeah this is unsustainable you know it's
it's insane I guess though that's my
point is that even the the Republican
Borough with the tough Italian Staten
Islanders most people haven't even heard
this story nothing really happened and
so look maybe something right right but
this is you're saying just wait and
it'll well so if the the revolutionary
period started in 1764 and it took 11
years to get to the point where people
were opening opening fire on regulars
you know we could be eight years away or
if the four if the straws house
generational theory is correct then
we're looking at maybe four I think in
four years we're in deep trenches of
serious conflict in in our Urban in the
United States yeah what about the world
do you think I can't imagine that
something would happen the United States
and not the rest of the world like it
would be a global Firestorm or something
like that if the US destabilizes in this
way
China immediately takes Taiwan and and
try and take the western United States
it would be like land grab Central like
if the Civil War or the Revolutionary
War was a French opportunity to take
control of the the Atlantic Ocean by
demolishing the British and they did
that so when you make a good point to
Ian which is you've already got this
this difficult situation we're in where
the the West led by America is decaying
and China is largely On The Rise so
you're seeing what people are calling
the inevitability of a bipolar World
already so cracking us hegemony for the
first time since the Cold War is Over
and frankly even a little earlier than
that so when you when you have a shift
in the world order to that degree it
almost always ends in war in a world war
so is it possible that just as we're on
the brink of our civil war and you know
pulling out our muskets to shoot our
cousins uh that we find ourselves in a
global conflict already where the stakes
are even higher yep does Russia Advance
knowing that the United States is
completely destabilized and if Russia
does do a larger push say with nuclear
artillery and I use that as an example
because I'm sure they have other weapons
and other techniques that could be
divisive and Powerful but a nuclear
weapon creates a hyperpolarization in
the United States one side the left
saying this is our Cassis belly we must
stop Vladimir Putin and the right would
say this is your fault we should not
have been in Ukraine in the first place
you caused this we need to extract and
and and remove ourselves now
and then what happens do you think after
a nuclear artillery is dropped in
Ukraine that there's I mean this this
would extreme political instability
already in this country
they're not going to have the public
support to Warrant sending more troops
more dollars more more resources to
Ukraine we now know thanks to CBS
surprisingly that the US is not only
funding the war we're funding the small
businesses of Ukraine right when the
federal government shuts down
Ukraine will still the U.S will be
paying the salaries of Ukrainian
citizens while not paying veterans
benefits now I do think netgate said
they did get a measure through a single
subject spending Bill to guarantee
veterans benefits they're duking it out
right now I mean as we're speaking
they're on the floor of the house right
now duking this out but but I the thing
I love about this government shutdown
look we now shut down the government
every year so I don't even pay attention
to it really this is just this year's
shutdown and the thing I love about it
is that it's going to show you who
really runs your government because just
as you say we're going to shut down all
non-essential services but those
paychecks to the shop owner in Ukraine
they're going to keep going it doesn't
matter what the people in Congress say I
I think from for most I think most
people in this country don't care
you tell them that tax dollars are going
to Ukraine they're going to be like I I
can't see it right I'll tell you
something funny
in uh you ever play poker you play
protection so you're familiar with table
rank versus time rake
no okay go to a casino and most of them
do what's called a table rake where that
that's every every every hand everyone
gets dealt two cards everybody puts
money in and then you can increase the
wager and if you can't if you don't want
to pay it you full
the casinos typically take five to seven
dollars out of the pot as what's called
a table rake so every hand that's dealt
they will pull ten percent up to six
dollars and put it in their bin that
means if they're doing 20 to 30 hands
per hour times six dollars
some some card clubs do what's called a
table rake which is I'm sorry A Time
rake every half an hour everyone pays
seven dollars
if you do what's what's called time rake
you physically pick the money up and
hand it to the to the dealer and you're
like that sucked if you do a table rake
you never know because the dealer is
pushing you your winnings and pulling
from it without you realizing and people
beg for table rake which takes
substantially more money away from them
the reason I bring this up is when it
comes to us funding Ukraine so long as
the American people can't see the money
extracted from their accounts they won't
care right as soon as if if it was the
if if Joe Biden said everyone's gonna
we're gonna debit your bank account five
dollars to fund the war in Ukraine there
would be a riot it'd be over in one
second but you know what they're really
gonna do is it's all funny money and
we're so incredibly in debt at this
point that people don't even pay
attention to it and well even even if
the Congress doesn't approve more
Appropriations for Ukraine which is
possible what's going to happen is
they're going to just discover another
six billion dollars the part of remember
this was a few months ago they
discovered six billion dollars they
meant to send to Ukraine and that that
wasn't really true that's not really
what happened what really happened is
the political Powers who were running
our war in Ukraine are side of the war
in Ukraine they decided that Ukraine
needed some more stuff so they
retroactively changed the price of the
weapons that we sent over and said no
actually look we appropriated this
amount of money and it turns out those
weapons they were cheaper than we
thought we just yeah we figured it out
though and anyway so we're gonna send it
more but it's okay we're not spending
any more money because we just uh
retroactively changed the prices okay
great thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time